all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for Donald Trump at the top
of the hour in a press propaganda event
but Mike Pence is also speaking right
now so I as a general policy on this
program we tend not to ever play any
audio of Mike Pence Oh what's up with my
graphics that's really weird I got to
get that fixed that's weird
we're gonna look at we're gonna look at
that very strongly momentarily I try not
to really do any pen snow there's my
graphics Pat's pen stuff because it's
just such propaganda nonsense but he is
speaking right now and I guess we'll
kind of keep it on the screen while we
are while we are chatting here at the
top of the hour roughly we are expecting
to hear from Donald Trump in another one
of these propaganda roundtables but it
is believed he will take questions and
Trump has been extremely triggered all
day on Twitter because of the Supreme
Court decision about daca which he lost
on because his administration made a
terrible legal argument quite frankly
it's actually plausible that they could
have won and I'm gonna have a full
analysis on tomorrow's podcast and
broadcast show and YouTube clips and all
of that stuff he also is hugely
triggered by John Bolton's book which
again exposes Trump as just as
incompetent as we believed him to be and
I I have a segment which I've already
recorded there's I just can we can the
can the hot take stop guys can is that
an is that a crazy request can we just
stop the stupid hot takes you've got the
hot take from the right which is nothing
Bolton says can be believed because he
did he's a disgruntled loser okay
obviously that's a dumb argument you've
got some on the Left there's so called
enlightened or sometimes I don't even
know what the right there's just some
people on the Left who are now coming
out with the position that all of these
dumb leftists who fell for Russia gate
who fell for impeachment who believed
Ukraine are now believing Bolton who's a
neoconservative Pro
Rock war but immoral whatever that's
also a really dumb argument okay so
we've got to be able to parse this stuff
is Bolton a traitor yeah I would say he
is and the reason Bolton's a traitor is
that the allegations he makes in his
book which I find widely believable
could have been made seven months ago
if Bolton really feels a patriotic duty
to inform us about what Donald Trump did
then he should have done it seven months
ago now why did he wait well mostly so
he could sell a book would be my guess
he could have gone and testified before
the House impeachment committee he could
have gone and done interview so yes
these allegations are so serious that I
believe it is traitorous to have held
them for seven months to put them in a
book but that doesn't mean they're not
true and that doesn't mean Bolton's a
good guy and it doesn't mean Bolton was
right to get us into the Iraq war and it
doesn't mean Bolton is no longer a
neoconservative tool so the you know I I
get that everybody's trying to be
interesting and get clicks and either be
contrarian or you know all this
different stuff all of these different
things are true at the same time and I
don't for a second believe John Bolton
is going to fabricate these allegations
out of thin air
they pass the sniff test because we've
been watching Trump for three and a half
years but at the same time I'm not gonna
go by Bolton's book and reward him for
holding on to this information for seven
months that I would argue that that is
traitorous so I'll have a deeper i've
got like a half-hour on Bolton that I'm
doing on today's show and the podcast
will be out in 30 minutes if you want to
subscribe to that on you know Spotify I
do where the hell do people listen to
podcasts I'm too fired up even to list
podcast platforms please okay
we are watching Mike Pence but we're not
going to listen to him and then we are
standing by for Donald Trump at the top
of the hour I'm hoping that Donald Trump
is going to be asked questions about his
tweets on daca the John Bolton stuff so
that's really I the proper
and a round table is essentially
worthless but I am hoping that we hear
some nasty questions so-called ask of
Donald Trump I prefer to call it
journalism not nasty questions let me
say a huge thank you to Celeste rusian
Celeste rusian is new member number one
today at join pakman.com and david
berger david berger is new member number
two today at join pakman.com I very much
appreciate that if you are just joining
us and you're wondering when the chess
tournament is it was two days ago
oh sorry I froze there it was two days
ago and we had 732 people play I came in
around a hundred and eightieth I think
Stephen Kenneth destiny banal ii played
the winner was international master Eric
Rosen and it was absolutely fantastic
that yeah I had to buffer and sometimes
I buffer in real life that's what
happened there so the chess tournament
is over but we will have a third chess
tournament at some point yeah the frozen
David meme a people there there's one
where I some point I froze when Trump
said something really crazy I think it
was a disposition oh sorry
and anyway that was um that was turned
into a meme and it's it's all I love it
I mean I love it I'm guessing it's like
17 year olds who are doing that but um
it was still really good real life
buffering okay super - all right noise
let me go first to twitch Suzy's Zack
Zack has subscribed for four months with
twitch prime and I very much appreciate
that thank you
over on YouTube the super chats are
pouring in like lies pour out of trumps
mouth Matt Chavez says what are your
thoughts on what the Supreme Court will
rule on Trump's taxes I have no idea I I
don't try to predict Supreme Court
rulings because it's just who knows JAF
94 says concerned Oklahoman here and we
have no number on today's cases yet yeah
Trump holding a rally in Oklahoma
upcoming
I will not be going and I don't
recommend that you go either
Zachary foster says lots of good news on
the vaccine now I didn't see any let me
see what we've got
let me pull up news.google.com uh and we
want to look for coronavirus vaccine I
didn't hear anything
Trump pushing officials to speed it up
moderna vaccine will be ready in 2021
okay that's what we expected I'm not
seeing anything particularly notable
about the vaccine so maybe send me
something if you're aware of something
in particular I think what we'll do is
we'll turn the audio up here but we'll
just keep our shot on pens
Jimmy big nuts says could you interview
vouch fastest-growing lefty eater oh my
goodness okay Eli Grace has become a
member david is the best period I'm
having trouble grammatically parsing
some of these super chats Marc says what
are your thoughts on recent North Korean
aggression
you know we discussed that on
yesterday's bonus show Marc so I'm I
don't want to I try to avoid redoing
content on the show so I'm not gonna cop
we did talk about that on the bonus show
though you like Grace's David are you
familiar with unicorn riot I it's I
think it's a band right I don't know
anything else about it
other than I believe that it's a band
thanks also to Thomas fields for signing
up for a youtube subscription at the
beta level and Sean McCracken says you
muted me I don't know what you're
talking about John you're I muted you
you're on screen right now Biden polling
impact stock drops you called it dumb oh
my god I have no clue what Sean's
talking about I'm a big fan and Liv
didn't mean to offend Sean D McCracken
is my Twitter Sean I say this with
complete and total peace and love and
endless humility I have no idea what
you're talking about
but we will look into it let me say
thank you to grav turn who has
subscribed with twitch prime which I
very very much appreciate it's
conceivable that we
may have a hype train triggered on
Twitch at some point in time we oh you
guys want to see a little cringe video I
think I'm gonna show it i retweeted this
yesterday this made me physically sick
okay this is I've got a print that was
also way way way too loud
see if we can do a little something
about that this is I guess people
already waiting in line for Trump's
Tulsa rally and see if I can show this
to you a little bigger just I mean just
take a look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way what is this guy holding is
this a speaker is this a purse is it
what like what is this a fanny pack that
he's removed I don't know what that is
[Applause]
[Music]
is this a family is it it seems almost
like one of those Mormon families with
ten kids
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know what's funny and now that
I've seen it a bunch of times it's weird
I am like desensitized to it now when I
saw that for the first time yesterday
oh wow look here is a tweet of me
watching this video with you guys right
now it's like Inception when I when I
tweeted it yesterday at 16 hours ago I
guess that would have been like seven
wait three four seven PM it made me feel
physically ill it only had like a
million views now it has 11 million
views and it actually seems all more
comedic at this point it's weird how
quickly I become desensitized to it very
very odd stuff but that that's just
absolutely sick let me say thank you to
Goku for the five months on Twitch prime
full metal crusade also 5 months and
says 5 months subbed on Twitch and over
a year on the website thank you very
much appreciate it we are now in the
we're in a full-blown hype train on
twitch right now we have already
achieved level 2 and it's we it's been a
while since we've succeeded on level 5
but we are on we are in the middle of a
hype train and it's getting extremely
extremely exciting okay questions coming
in via super chat Zachary Foster says
news on vaccine okay let's take a look
at this let me let me first vet it
before I don't want to put like a
swastika up on the screen Oxford
University scientists 80% vaccine would
work and it could be ready in a few
weeks oh my god a corona fight let's
let's take a look at that how triggered
would Trump be if it's a different
country who does it a corona virus
vaccine developed by scientists at
Oxford administered using an inhaler
could be ready as early as August Irish
scientist professor Adrian from Oxford
University's Center for personalized
medicine said researchers are 80%
confident the vaccine that will work
could the the arrival could depend on
whether transmission rates continue to
decline it could be around August it
might be before if cases do not decline
as quickly as we expect or later if we
run out of cases warned the research
could be slowed of transmission rates
fall too low if
a few volunteers catch the virus they
would be unable to immediately
accurately assess whether it is
effective that is amazing that is
absolutely stunning news thank you for
pointing it out you know a lot of
countries have basically fixed
coronavirus but we haven't as you can
see here very very ugly Trump pretending
like it's over but we had 26,000 new
cases yesterday it's really really about
active cases on the rise deaths have
still been declining which is good but
you know we're probably still a few days
out from seeing the effect on deaths of
the the recent spikes that we've been
seeing since early June so we very much
need a vaccine and it may indeed be you
know a different a different country
that ends up with it but that is
absolutely amazing absolutely amazing
news about the vaccine thank you to
jason nash whose new member number three
on my website join pakman.com appreciate
that Jason we have about two minutes to
achieve a level two hype train over on
twitch which is extremely exciting if
you're just joining us we're expecting
to hear from Donald Trump roughly at the
top of the hour hopefully he will be
asked about John Bolton hopefully he
will be asked about the Supreme Court
decisions that have gone against him
Michael Blanco says hey David will you
be streaming the tools
Oklahoma rally you know I probably will
not I'm going to be out of town over the
weekend for Father's Day
and I probably am NOT going to stream it
but I'm a stream futures from brow I
mean I disagree that they should even be
taking place so it's sort of you know I
have to think about even the impact of
me streaming it I'm gonna think about
that
Sean McCracken says it's tough with this
word limits sorry I wasn't clear it was
on Twitter I said Biden's polling causes
a market drop you said it was dumb and
muted okay I have no recollection of
that I I don't believe that the market
is reacting to Biden's polling and also
the market does better under Democratic
presidents than Republicans and it's not
by a small margin so that seems very
counterintuitive to me Jeff 94
as my state is embarrassing I'm sorry
apology accepted
Thomas Fletcher sends a super chat Eli
gray says unicorn riot is a
not-for-profit media okay it's not a
band that live streams from the front
lines at protests all of the country on
YouTube seriously check it out all right
I will
nasty question says thoughts on Matt
Gaetz his non-white child I saw one
tweet I know very very little about him
Tyler in the residence says my favorite
part of the David Pakman chess
tournament was David watching David try
to checkmate with two rooks and he ended
up chasing the King around very strong
elements of comedy yeah I after the fact
when I analyzed I realized all I had to
do was play a waiting move like moving
my king and then it would have forced my
opponent's King into a position where I
would have had matin one essentially so
listen I never I said I would run a nice
clean chess tournament even though some
people were caught cheating incredibly
oh we have hit level three on the hype
train thank you very much appreciate
that I said we would probably have more
than players than the first time and we
did we had 732 instead of 500 I didn't
say I was good at chess I never said I
was good at chess so that is uh no
change as far as that's concerned okay
nettie 505 has subscribed with prime dr.
wag 85 has subscribed with prime wafer
is a new prime subscriber control
constructs of insult has subscribed very
much appreciate that and we are now
working on level three hype train
I see Pence is doing something weird I
just refuse to carry this in terms of
from the standpoint of audio so we're
watching pence but we're waiting for
Trump and that's the that that's the
gist the dark half v2 says at least that
family has rhythm
just kidding love the show and service
David smash the like and subscribe
button oh by the way I have not
mentioned this for a while because we're
just so like there's just no time to do
it
but because we have a minute now our
YouTube channel
has exploded over the last two weeks we
are already beyond 860 thousand YouTube
subscribers and we are I mean you know I
don't know when we're on track to hit a
million but we're certainly very
strongly headed at naught to 900,000
which is just unbelievable
so yes if you are watching on YouTube
like and subscribe it's all free and
nothing to sneeze out on Twitch either
we are still very powerfully streaming
on Twitch and working we're still
working on our first 50,000 followers on
Twitter
let me say thank you to Karstens Einar
Carstens Einar is new member number four
today at join pakman.com we are standing
by here for Donald Trump and another one
of these propaganda roundtable events I
will mention that all of this stuff that
we do the podcasts the YouTube clips the
live streams the chess tournaments the
live phone calls all of the stuff we
mostly depend on people who just grab a
membership on my website I know that
there's a lot of confusion people
wondering it do I have a money tree in
my urban garden how do we pay staff
salaries and equipment and connectivity
it's mostly just people who go to join
pakman.com and get a membership that's
really it and as I've said many times
before we do this show for everybody
only about half of one percent of our
audience subscribes in any financial
sense but if you are in a position where
a dollar or two a month is something you
can contribute to a channel that
hopefully you like I'm inviting you
right now to go to join pakman.com the
coupon code 2020 now does save you 66%
that makes a membership 2 bucks a month
if you pay for the year it's a dollar 80
a month ok so if you've been hit by the
virus if you've been what if you're one
of the 45 million people who lost their
job because of the virus if you've seen
a reduction in hours or we're here we're
here for you we're gonna keep doing the
show every single weekday and the
streams and the entire thing if if if if
you are in a position where
you could get a $2.00 a month membership
I invite you to do it and I will thank
every single person who signs up so like
for example John Hughes just signed up
love that beautiful name John Hughes is
new member number five today five at
join pakman.com and I will make sure
everybody everybody gets a thank you
very much appreciated okay other super
chats are coming in no wow I actually
hold on a second I'm inconsolable has
just gifted ten subscriptions on Twitch
I'm inconsolable is the top ever gift er
of subscriptions on Twitch
I believe I'm inconsolable hold on I
can't see it right now
how many memberships as I'm inconsolable
gifted there's just a lot of animations
happening right now I can't even tell
it's not showing me okay but in any case
we are on a level five hypetrain
happening exactly Oh 346 someone says
very good 346 that's incredible
alright other folks itching to get in
here oli piece says UK vaccine being
mass-produced ready for launch yeah we
got the article incredible news truly
incredible news Ren Holder 57 says can
this skeleton monster off get off the
stage
yeah we're just showing video of pence
but we're really waiting for Trump he
should be he's only eight minutes late
so far so it could still be a little bit
but we're keeping a very very close eye
on it Seth Barham says via super chat hi
David I live in rural North Carolina and
can report many are ashamed to wear
masks because it's a conservative era
area and a cultural issue now we're
screwed
I feel bad for North Carolina I feel bad
for Texas I feel bad for Arizona Florida
Florida both states I feel bad for and
it's it's just it's really really bad
and I am not planning on leaving
Massachusetts for a while I'm going on a
little socially distant vacation next
week but I am staying within
Massachusetts just because I know the
policies I sort of trust
what's going on I can trust the data I
can trust the data and there's a lot of
great places to go in Massachusetts you
can go camping
you've got the Berkshires you've got
Cape Cod you've got Martha's Vineyard
Nantucket there's just listen it's I'm
staying within the state for the time
being that's that's my plan a sasquatch
hunter says Alaska here so PFD but ubi
ploy by right math my goodness I don't
know what that's about but I do
appreciate the support
Sean McCracken says I'm a stock
enthusiast I absolutely agree the data
backs your opinion on the market I
wanted to clarify my support of you and
your content you're exploding because
you're the best in my opinion Thank You
Sean
I appreciate that Alec says I'm a huge
fan enjoy your videos every day it is
nicer to hear some Ries it is nice to
hear some reasonable logical ideas for a
change our country is becoming crazy
very much so very much so
Joe Grover the effin game cat says if
Trump does events in key states and
makes many people sick can he shut down
voting if he makes enough people sick
and call it an emergency no it would
actually make the case stronger for
vote-by-mail which Trump opposes which
is which is crazy let me say thank you
to penguin TV for subscribing over on
Twitch also I'm inconsolable just
continues to gift subscriptions
meticulous seven with a nine month Prime
subscription has achieved hype train
level five we've done it folks we've
done it I'm inconsolable has just gifted
another ten subscriptions over on Twitch
it is wacky what is going on I've read
about stuff like this happening but I've
never experienced it myself it's a real
party over on Twitch right now it's
gonna be hard to console me quite
frankly ok other folks who are signing
up on my website let me say thank you to
Chris Wilson whose new member number six
today Brian Young is new member number
seven
Robert McQueen is new member number 8
Marcie Kerry is new member number 9 I
also want to say thanks to Ruben Ramirez
new member number 10 I love it
Julie Felix is new member number 11 and
Michael limas is new member number 12
today at join pakman.com it's crazy
what's happening on my website really
really crazy right now there seemed to
be seems to be 23 people in progress
right now getting memberships that's
crazy
that is really wacky okay other super
chats coming in unknown geek says
apparently Beethoven is black due to his
mother being Moorish oh my god I have no
idea if so we should look into figures
ancestries to stop history from being
whitewashed that's actually an
interesting thing if a lot of people are
presumed to be white and they actually
weren't it is an interesting thing from
a sociological standpoint okay we are
still waiting oh this is over here so
Pence is done alright so now we're just
waiting for Trump very good Herald
Lemoine has subscribed on YouTube Lee
has subscribed on YouTube Billy big
brick says hey David how about that coup
in Bolivia Danny Thompson says I laugh
thinking about as far as paid
memberships to you as concerned I am a
member of the top one half of one
percent for sure the only way in life I
will be able to say that Thank You Danny
van a Dulles says what is that orange
hairpiece talking about now we don't
know yet but we're hoping hoping for
some very powerful journalistic nasty
questions asked of Donald Trump am i
taking phone calls somebody people are
asking in chat if I'm taking phone calls
after the stream probably not I've got
to go out and reseed my lawn
I've got patchy grass right now so I
went over to the garden center earlier
and I bought some patch to repair so I'm
gonna be having a real party out in the
yard after the stream receding my lawn
so I probably will not be
taking phone calls today but it is
something that we could look at doing
very very soon took phone calls a couple
times last week
waffles derp awful says Trump water zip
seems more like a tick / OCD
Oh his sipping water yeah a lot of
theories hypotheses about that JL
Switzerland sends a super chat with no
message Krieg st. says nice shape up is
that is that a haircut thing I think
you're talking about my haircut
very good James brink water well where
did that go says why is it still that
why is it that still millions of
Americans support that obvious con man
is it possible that after losing to
Biden Trump will run again in four years
now he'll be like 80 years old what do
you think of libertarian candidate dr.
Joe never heard of him or her no idea
Gregory shavers says I was in South
Carolina for a few days and people
stared at me my girlfriend and her
family for wearing masks scary times it
is scary it is scary Patrick Miller says
hey buddy was wondering if you had to
choose between having a dinner with
Hassan or do I owe Hassan I say Hassan
or destiny which would you choose
well I last time I was in LA I had
dinner with both of them so I don't know
why I have to choose other than the fact
that they seem to hate each other now I
would never - I mean listen I would just
have dinner with one of them one night
and the other the next night if they
aren't able to be around each other what
else can I say let me say a few other
thank-yous to people that are grabbing
memberships Jane Sylvester is new member
number 13 today Alex bages is new member
number 14 today Teresa Thakur is new
member number 15 today Kristin or kit
Miller is new member number 16 today
very much appreciate the support and
okay one person says that that coupon
code isn't working it is working because
a whole bunch of people are using it
it's possible possible that it's user
error possible that it's user error I'm
not sure about that
but it seems to be working just fine few
messages are coming in via twitch mr.
Lyall miss certain is MS Earl I'll says
you're my favorite coverage of the
cheeto in chief much love from Canada
thank you I appreciate that
typhoid games has also subscribed as
well as Attila too and moot bar a lot
happening today very active on twitch
very very active Michael asks have you
seen the new Lincoln project ad yes I
have a whole clip about it on my youtube
channel which you can take a look at
bacon lovers has how did corona become a
political issue what isn't what isn't
political these days whoa
Sasquatch hunter says PFD Permanent Fund
dividend oh that's the the oil dividend
I believe in Alaska right I did not know
that's what it was called Jr says I
watched and interviewed it you did on
Fox 2 years ago with Dom wherein you
noted you may have looked intentionally
whiter than the others would you ever be
interviewed on Fox again or have you
okay that regard there's some
explanation let me see if I can pull
this up I looked intentionally whiter
let's see progressive David Pakman Fox
News let me see if I could okay so
here's the video while we're waiting for
Trump so I was I was my knee of you know
but let's go check out the video so I
was on Fox News a little while ago see
how the white balance is such that this
guy looks tan and Leland Vetter or
Vitter - look Stan but I look like a
freakin ghost can anybody see that so
I'm not saying they did this to me on
purpose but when I walked into the
studio like I'm familiar with the color
temperature of my lights and I have a
monitor I've any number of monitors I
know like when I see the lighting and I
see the monitor I know if the cut what
the color temperature needs to be for me
not to look like this right so the
second I walked in to that studio just
looking at the lights I was
this looks a little too white for me and
then when I saw myself on the monitor I
was like I look I look absolutely sickly
here and obviously as you can tell
everybody else seems to have proper
lighting other other than me
so I don't know that they did it on
purpose the truth is if they had seen
that I was coming into light to where
they mix the three shots they could have
done color correction just on my shot
and fixed it so certainly nobody seemed
to be making any effort to fix it so
yeah I mean it was probably indifference
to some degree we're still waiting on
Trump but I don't even remember this
let's listen to a little bit of it
there's whether it be John Huntsman
National Security Advisor Bouldin or
others they are far harsher in their
rhetoric than the president
what do you it'd be mentioned this guy
looks like an idiot right I mean like
the color that his skin looks I don't
know if that's spray tan or if he got
totally yellow light like I'm not trying
to look like this but I look ill I look
ill make of it that's true Leland and I
wish the President were a harsher in his
but the actions of President Trump what
his administration is actually doing we
put more sanctions on Putin we've kicked
out more of the delegates from the
Soviet before this guy has this guy from
Philly and he has the same accent as
Jimmy from Philly not surprisingly from
Russia so his actions have been firm in
this manner and I think it's way
overblown that he's going to give away
the store a president Trump is not going
to do that in any kind of negotiation I
wish the rhetoric though we're more
direct toward putin that's where i
usually ask david it brings up an
interesting point it is the less problem
so i'm smirking here because this guy is
not really bringing up an interesting
point the president Trump among many
that they have the way he goes about
foreign policy or actually the substance
of it because his David points out our
Dom points out he's been pretty tough on
Putin much tougher than Obama in many
ways by selling youthful weapons to the
Ukrainians yeah I think that the problem
really is the easily manipulable reality
of Donald Trump and I think if we want a
sort of a preview of what we could
expect with Putin we look at what
happened with Kim jong-un where the way
Boston radio hosts
Austan radio host or Donald Trump
claimed victory on the basis of the
exact same vague promises that we've
gotten from North Korea before tweeted
on the way back that the nuclear threat
is over and we just learned that you
didn't interrupt the orange guy why are
you interrupting me
in that vein the president just tweeted
even this morning he said wait a second
he said it's been nine months there
hasn't been a nuclear test and there
hasn't actually forgotten that I
couldn't really interrupt him but I
signaled I was Donald from an acclaimed
victory on the basis of the exact same
vague promises that we've gotten from
North Korea before tweeted on the way
back that the nuclear threat is over and
we just learned that in that vein the
president just tweeted even this morning
he said wait a second it's been nine
months there hasn't been a nuclear test
and there hasn't been a missile test so
there's the first interval okay so then
I this is me talking about me talking
about me on on Fox News anyway that
entire thing is is on is on YouTube and
you guys can certainly find that okay I
I don't want to fall behind because my
website is barely able to keep up with
some of the signups that are happening
here I want to say thank you to Jerry
schmear
Jerry schmear is number 17 today Sarah
Sten accan is new member number 18 today
Maria Bohm is new member number 19 today
Jason Lawrence is new member number 20
and Bradley Hollingsworth coming in out
of nowhere shot out of a cannon Bradley
is new member number 21 today very much
appreciate that the coupon code is under
full power 2020 now is a 66% discount
which is just crazy I also want to say
thank you over on Twitch too in your
groove for subscribing with twitch prime
psychologism x' has subscribed with
prime big bad Brad has subscribed with
prime as well very very much appreciate
that okay if you're just joining us
Donald Trump was scheduled to speak 22
minutes ago as you can tell he hasn't
yet started and we are standing by the I
don't really care what he's going to say
about Governors
it's just a propaganda event but the
hope is that Trump will take questions
from the press and that there will be
powerful questions about John Bolton
about Trump losing again at the Supreme
Court etc etc okay let me get back to
some super chats parity Ren says happy
midsummer to all tomorrow
I thought June 21 was the midst was uh
oh wait no midsummer that must be a
Swedish thing right the proletariat says
hey David I cut the tail under the chess
tournament I heard you mentioned destiny
complaining about something are you guys
beefing now we are not beefing I don't
do fake beefs I know that it has been
recommended to me that I do fake beefs
with someone I'm not beefing with
Stephen Kenneth destiny bonel ii I'm not
beefing with Hassan destiny [ __ ] ii I'm
not beefing period I'm just doing my
thing
squee Dao has subscribed on YouTube
where'd that go there it is
pixie mat Madeline says I stand with
that woman from Michigan great kovat
nineteen numbers beautiful he Lansing
success has subscribed at the SOI boy
level Patrick Miller says what if they
were only serving lamb yeah I told a
story when I was when I was interviewing
Stephen Kenneth the other day about when
I went to dinner with Hassan [ __ ] and
Stephen and I jokingly said maybe
Stephen didn't like what Hassan ordered
but I it was just a joke it was just a
joke Sam rule says hello from Vermont
nothing important to highlight just
wanted to make a contribution on top of
my membership to my favorite favorite
independent news channel thanks Sam we
love Vermont we love Vermont Jacob
Ratner says what's your take on the
North Korea situation I was I was asked
about that about 15 minutes ago we did a
segment on yesterday's bonus show about
it so I'm going to forego that topic
right now and I say that with peace and
love yellow lemon says Pakman destiny
Jesse Lee Peterson podcast that's an
idea horror fan for life says David what
is your view on Tariq Nasheed debate
I don't know to Rika sheeds views so I
would not be able to say Mart Fillion
says yesterday Kaylee McKenna and Annie
said that Trump is concerned about kids
security and well-being so what should
we said to the children that live in
cages for so long yes your point is
that's still going on and it's
absolutely horrifying the blue Nobel
says David
you really should grow dragon fruit just
grab a cutting potted up and make a
simple trellis I recommend the light or
sugar dragon will that grow in uh in in
Boston I'd be curious to know about them
I want to say thanks to hack Huey hack
phooey on twitch who subscribed with the
message hope you were having a good day
Camry just gifted five subscriptions I'm
just gonna drink water real quick hope
people saw what I did there
and Luke daddy Luke daddy has also
subscribed for two months Ella Willig
says what's the probability of Trump
still being successful in stopping dak
daca daca um
I addressed that on a segment about this
if Donald Trump is reelected there's a
good chance he stops daca because the
reason the Supreme Court said no dice
was not that daca has to stay the
Supreme Court said Trump's argument for
undoing Obama's order is not sufficient
so if Trump actually got proper lawyers
he could probably end daca and that is
yet another reason why we've got to get
rid of them we've just got to get him
out right away and not give him another
opportunity to do it
wha s says hey Dave hey Christian
gaffe-filled says don't you think it's
unethical for kailia to wear a crucifix
while flying
I mean I don't care you know I'm not I'm
not Christian but it seems that it would
go against her own religious views my
guess is that if she was confronted she
would she would tell herself she's lying
for the greater good and so Jesus would
be okay with it
Patrick Miller says ok one more and I'll
stop if you destiny and Hasan were on an
unsteady bridge that collapsed and you
had them both on if and you had them
both of them on each of your hands but
you could only save one which would you
pick so I I mean let I want to just give
you a very very specific a logistical
thing Steven Kenneth destiny Bunnell ii
and i are roughly the same size Hasan is
like twice my size my guess is I would
have a much more difficult time holding
Hasan up than I would holding Steven up
this is a weight issue it is not
political it is nothing other than like
Hasan weighs twice as much as Steven
Kenneth so I I mean it's just I would
have to make a call based on that that's
just it's just a it's it's you know I
don't I abide by the rules of gravity I
didn't make them I think is the point
I'm trying to make angel Perez says hey
David what do you think about the new
1.5 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
I have not seen that I have notes I
would have to take a look at it
Jane womanpower says hi nice to be here
great to see you Jane I very much
appreciate that I also want to say
thanks to gift friars el de Freer's el
for subscribing on Twitch with the
message I enjoy your level-headed news
commentary thank you very much I
appreciate that I also want to say thank
you to Brian Allen's
or Brienne I can't tell if it's Brianna
or Brian in any case you are new member
number 22 today at join pakman.com so we
are a half hour past when this event was
supposed to start I do want to take a
look at Trump's triggered Twitter to see
if there's any update about this 41
minutes ago first thing the anarchists
did upon taking over Seattle was build a
wall
see I was ahead of our times oh my
goodness that is like weaponized idiocy
weaponized so he tweeted a bunch a
little while ago when is he when is he
starting this is very strange very very
strange
I will oh people are asking so a couple
things so we got potentially very good
news from Oxford University they are now
saying they may have an inhaler
coronavirus vaccine by August which is
just absolutely incredible we're gonna
talk more about that but also I'm just
gonna replay some cringe video for you
one more time yesterday when I played
this it made me physically ill I'm a
little desensitized to it now but check
out these people I guess it's a family I
don't know waiting for the Trump Tulsa
rally
check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is the cultish stuff that we're
fighting my friends we are we it is it's
it's absolutely horrifying and you know
that it's just that's that's just what
we're fighting that's what it is
and we've got a we've got to do what we
can Willie b3 gaming has subscribed with
prime and says love the content keep up
the good work thank you I appreciate
that very very much also a big THANK YOU
to Marcy Carrie
Marcy Carrie who is new member number 23
today on my website join pakman.com okay
super chats let's see what else is
coming in here way I missed a bunch
Larry Kemp's has just wanted to stop by
with the donation been a subscriber to
your channel for a while
I loved your take Biden I'm from Atlanta
Georgia do you think Keisha Lance
bottoms has a chance of being Biden's
vice president I do not I do not believe
that is likely Patrick Miller says sure
it's just a weight issue the blue Nobel
says it could grow outdoors in the
summer dragon fruit they are fairly easy
to grow if you use a simple compost to
fertilize it choose red pink and purple
flesh to type oh my goodness
Lance Power says surprised about the
Trump health rumors I get that we can't
trust anything he says but we also don't
have evidence and he could just be old
he could just build and we've talked
about that possibility as well
Andrew Dwyer says have you been
following Jamaal Bowman is the the next
day OC I have been following a little
bit I I don't know you know next day OC
I'm not really sure horror fan for life
says as a biracial black man I'm
convinced 90% of conservatives are
racist sad but true they defend racism
until the end plus Trump is a well-known
racist okay see M Wells says are you a
one-man show or do you have a production
team no we have a production team and
you know it so when when I thank people
like Paul Abreu
who is new member number 24 and other
people who saw
upon my website you're really supporting
the entire thing you know we this this
is this is a program where we help
people with health insurance when they
need it we you know what people don't
just let it's not oh well here we are
let's see what's going on from
struggling with technology yes we have a
full production team we have a staff of
four I'm just kind of waiting around
this is weird
okay this is not yes all right wait
flora says David speaking of cringe what
about the Stephen coward video haven't
seen it I don't watch this stuff
Dylan McDonald says saludos this the
Tijuana greetings from Tijuana I'm a
dual citizen living in Tijuana and
usually okay thank you very much oh it's
an honor to see you all today in this
beautiful afternoon yeah it has we're
here today to discuss our efforts to
support our nation's small businesses
working very hard and safely reopen
America and that's what's happening by
the way guys this is the president just
a reminder there's like nobody has ever
seen before actually I'm thrilled to be
joined by two good friends of mine
governor pete ricketts of nebraska Pete
Ricketts very much and a man that I'm
gonna see a little bit over the weekend
and this was a really by coincidence
that you happen to be here today because
that's for a different reason it's a
small business governor
Kevin state of Oklahoma heaven's tip and
we're gonna be in Oklahoma and it's a
crowd like I guess nobody's seen before
we have a tremendous tremendous request
for tickets like I think probably has
never happened politically before never
and one of the reasons we chose your
state as you know Kevin was that you've
done so so well with the covered so
that's very untrue Kevin's tit was
actually out at restaurants when every
other state was locked down posting
pictures of himself he ended up having
to delete the picture because it was so
so horrible from their state also with
us a secretary of the Treasury Stephen
minuchin and small business
administrators Jovita Thank You Jovita
very good small business is no longer
small business it's big business it's
one of the biggest businesses as a
result of the virus 22 percent of small
businesses were forced to close
earlier this year including 41% of black
owned businesses but under my
administration strategy to vanquish the
virus and restart our economy scored
small businesses across the nation are
now safely reopening all over the nation
they're reopening at levels like
nobody's seen before many unsafe we're
sheltering individuals
the highest risk if you look at really
high risk individuals we are really
watching them and we're taking care of
who even knows we know what this is but
largely it means older people especially
older people senior citizens that have
the a tremendous they have a problem if
they have a heart problem if they have
diabetes if they have any kind of a
problem I am much more susceptible so
we're all we're all watching that very
closely we've learned a lot over the
last number of months yeah in the past
four months we've conducted over 25
million coronavirus tests and
distributed over 1.5 billion pieces of
personal protective equipment America is
better supplied and more prepared to
reenter then I would say just about any
other place with ventilators yeah look
at Spain Switzerland Taiwan Greece
Iceland New Zealand Austria I mean it's
like are we better prepared are we worse
prepared is the question than any other
place all stocked up our country is
totally stocked up everybody has their
ventilators that Perrin Aksum um they
can use love Paris well we are sending
them to other countries the nice part
and I say it a lot yeah because I think
it's pretty amazing when we came here
you had very few ventilators in this
country and by the time we start a birth
person that needed a ventilator didn't
get it so everybody that needed a
ventilator got a ventilator
there wasn't one instance anywhere in
our country we believe that Sundra we
stocked up those shelves the cupboard
was empty and we filled up the cupboards
cupboards in the past four months
tremendous things have happened but I
think probably the biggest thing of all
is the knowledge that we've gained of
this disease of this plague of this
virus right like months of it Trump
thought maybe we inject bleach that's
something he learned I approved over 670
billion dollars for the paycheck
protection program and Steve that's been
a tremendous success ended up being a
huge slush fund for Trump's friends
incredibly doing something further now
but the numbers the way they're coming
in it's been
incredible so we're able to spot it but
we're here to help businesses and to
help people to date we've processed over
4.6 million small business loans saving
and supporting an estimated 50 million
American jobs Jovita that's incredible
the small business owners that we have
with us this afternoon all receive the
PPP loans and now their businesses are
in the road to recovery and they're
doing really well we have a lot of
businesses that are doing really well
we're talking about a v-shape we're
almost like a nice shape is straight up
and down but I talked about B shape and
a lot of people disagreed with me not
everybody but a lot of very smart Wall
Streeters were disagreeing now they're
much coming pretty much coming on board
is the dot above the eye play into an
eye shaped recovery we were shooting for
and it looks like that's what we've got
I want to thank our people and my
representatives for their decisive
actions and last month we added a record
2.5 million jobs it's the highest in the
history of our country at one month
that's the highest number of jobs that
okay go back and look at my video clip
called you're about to get slammed with
garbage math I literally predicted this
is exactly what they would say after
record declines when things start to
come back they would say we're growing
faster than we've ever grown before as
if people are stupid because tens of
millions are unfortunately
fourth-quarter and next year's gonna be
a phenomenal year I believe that Nasdaq
actually set the record naturally
academic Nasdaq just said Nasdaq
statement so it was higher than even
before it's an amazing it's an amazing
achievement Nasdaq after I was elected
president our country added more than 7
million jobs 12,000 factories and
trillions of dollars of wealth and
created nearly 9,000 opportunity zones
an african-american Asian American and
Hispanic American unemployment of
poverty reached all-time lows with the
greatest employment numbers we've ever
had and then we had to turn it off we
save millions of people by doing it we
did the right thing and now we're
turning it back on and the numbers
are going up much much faster than
anybody would have thought powerfully
and it's a great honor to see it and
these two governors by the way of doing
it done a fantastic job two very
extraordinary men Nebraska and Oklahoma
yeah we built the strongest economy the
world has ever seen it's actually hard
to think of a worse governor than the
Oklahoma governor did it before the
virus when to turn it off and now we're
doing it again and that's what's
happening so now I'd like to maybe we'll
start off with governor Ricketts and
then we'll get to my friend over here
I'll be seeing so much of you in the
next couple of days I'll take you a
second thank you very much please well
thank you very much mr. president to all
of your team here we really appreciate
your effort your leadership and that of
your teams to be able to help us through
this pandemic and really give us the
tools to be able to manage it thanking
Trump we should if Trump had done
nothing we would have been better off
and just let Governors actually handle
it with medical doctors advantage of
that and really cover over 80% of our
payroll so it really was a fantastic way
to be able to keep people working we had
the third lowest unemployment rate in
April and we want to keep people in
their jobs we really appreciate all the
work they're doing and we've you know
you may recall we're one of the few
states that didn't issue a stay at home
order oh we know shelter in place order
yeah
what we did is try to take comments to
set steps and ask people to take
responsibility to be able to to follow
the directives that you all were putting
out with regard to avoiding large groups
washing their hands that sort of thing
and making sure they keep you know six
feet distance in public that sort of
thing and by doing that and targeting
specific higher risk businesses that we
asked to shut down for a shorter period
of time we were able to be able to stand
the less articulate jeff bezos everybody
in our state right now we had since the
end of April so it's got a nice
bell-shaped curve
up and now has come back down our cases
are steady and flat and now we're just
really the motive of they'll manage this
you know you put the ten person a rule
in place in mid-march and that bought us
the time to be able to strengthen our
contact tracing or testing our PPE so
let me just give you a guys a bit of a
hint here all of this stuff about Trump
put in these shutdowns in March Trump
way after every reasonable state had
already said this is what we need to do
came out and gave some guidelines which
states can follow or not follow so he
deserves no praise for that whatsoever
sure so we got kind of the double whammy
agriculture in particular has really
taken a heavy hit between what happened
then you know last year with the
flooding and then of the pandemic this
year but again your administration has
been helpful you know the phase one
China deal for example gives a great
mark to be able to sell things so we
really appreciate all that you're doing
to help us recover through these
terrible tragedies and they are buying a
lot aren't they they are they are helps
that make such a difference mr.
president particularly new lens on that
now with John Bolton saying Trump
literally asked the Chinese president to
help him get reelected by having China
buy stuff from American farmers it's
hilarious now that that that we now have
more context for the China stuff I think
they're animals so there's a lot of
impacting agriculture and your
administration has been great and
working with us to be able to help them
throat that's great thank you very much
thanks appreciate it governor well thank
you so much for having us mr. president
and on behalf of Oklahoma we're so
excited to have you and and like you
said I don't know this may be the worst
governor in the mean America he's
definitely a competitor for that come to
this event so it's just gonna be an
amazing no Oklahoma's ready for your
visit it's gonna be safe and we're
really really excited but you know
during this whole Kovach crisis as we've
been fighting in your administration has
been having calls twice a week the vice
president have been so helpful to myself
and all the other governors listening to
what our needs were and providing
everything we need so it's just been
been going great and so we're one of the
first states that has safely and
measurably reopened we went through we
went to Phase three on June first so
we're 56 days into our reopening plan
and currently we have under 200 people
in the hospital across the state of
Oklahoma tell me in chat who you think
is a worse governor than this guy number
of cases and so something the media
tries to talk about that but we knew we
were gonna have an increase a little bit
because we're 56 days into reopening but
what's interesting it's the 18 to 35
group that we've seen a slight increase
but they're the asymptomatic and we're
testing so many more people right now
then we were initially in the positive
cases are still 3.8 percent
so we've seen a steady decline in the
hospitalizations and we have to learn I
tell Oklahomans that kovat is in the
u.s. it's in Oklahoma we have to learn
how to be safe and how to have to move
on and so we were able to build capacity
because the whole reason I dish when t5
executive orders in Oklahoma was to
build capacity in our hospitals and also
the PPE and we were able to do that and
really flatten that curve Kevin's tit
feels to me like the guy who if you just
pay him enough he will literally say
anything anything anything you can
imagine he will say if the price is
right
and that's exactly what we've done and
Oklahomans are being safe and we can see
it in our numbers but we're ready to get
things back to normal get life back to
normal so again we can't wait to have
you in Oklahoma on Saturday
great job Kevin thank you thank you very
much Joe viateur please
you're gonna have to get a mic honor
also oh thank you and also to be able to
visit many businesses throughout the
state's I traveled to North Carolina as
well as Dallas and visit with the
faith-based and the lending community as
well as small businesses to to feel and
see and she runs the Small Business
Administration she's meeting with
churches what not only in the
faith-based not only in the small
businesses but also the lending
community what more can we do to
facilitate more capital for the small
businesses the underserved committee
communities are also being sought after
we've asked the lenders the very diverse
lenders that we've signed up over 50 400
of them to provide outreach very
aggressive outreach to our inner cities
and underserved communities I've spoken
with some of the governor's I've spoken
with the mayor's as well that we need to
do more there's over a hundred billion
dollars available remaining in the PPP
program a very successful program you've
shared Laurie that how you've been able
to transition your business from a very
high end to take out and still maintain
the customer base and we're realizing
this mr. president throughout the states
and every state that we visit now the
fact that SBA has been able to have a
touch point of over 10 million small
businesses we have 50 million that you
indicated of employees in one portfolio
and another about nine million in the
other portfolio so at some point we will
be providing technical assistance
providing some coaching and counseling
to be able to solidify those
relationships that the new businesses
have developed with the lending
community so I thank you president thank
you very much and you know they've done
like more business in four days than
they did in four years right it's a big
it's become a big business small
business is now big business so thank
you thank you doing a great job thank
you very much Steve please mr. president
thank you it's a problem out there and
it's great to see
your economic programs working
especially for small businesses the PPP
has been a tremendous success we've seen
that in the employment numbers we still
have more work to do we want to make
sure that every single person who lost
their job because okay if it gets back
to work and we won't be done until that
happens and I'm also pleased that this
week working with the Federal Reserve
we've opened the Main Street funding
facility again that will possible
businesses down to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar loans so again a massive
amount of liquidity that's been pumped
into the system for small businesses
today
oh is this Cutler well I'm weekly
unemployment claims fell for the 11th
straight week it's a good sign gonna
have job numbers in June and I think
would be very strong yeah fell but still
twice the previous record before this
entire thing Bert I think the PPP was
superhuman probably saved 55 million
jobs and we saw that with a three
million dollar three million job
increase in the May numbers I compiled
my list of green shooting sir we've got
yeah Apple mobility for traveling almost
back to his pandemic pre-pandemic high
seems more drunk homebuilder demand and
confidence is very very strong
automobiles car sales are moving from
eight point six million to 12 point two
million as the factories reopen as you
noted the retail sales number was a
spectacular 18 percent Michigan consumer
expectations very strong today and if I
be optimism index expect economy to wait
a second wait a second jump they've been
criticizing Michigan for months now it
seems Michigan did something right and
they're taking credit for it
dutour activity indexes are off the
charts if I play reference to the
Congressional Budget Office it will get
a 20% increase in q3 which i think is
quite possible 20% increase in q4 what
that smirk on my percent increase in hue
20:21 we will be back to where we were
in 2019 we will have made up for the
lost ground hazing it's not gonna take
the Tigers
we will made it up with some decent
numbers by the first but hopefully a
different present by then
that's called a super V right super V I
like the eyes let's go the V it's called
the V Plus that's why we headed to great
things
Chinese plague so you know that happens
too and things happen then you know late
sometimes so but we built it once we're
now building it again and it's gonna be
even more successful in my opinion
Kaylee please Oh No yes mr. president
why does she even if she's just the
spokesperson for Trump why does she get
to speak when Trump is here sizing
because it's exactly that 2.5 million
jobs added blowing past expectations you
had the experts off by about 10 million
jobs that's quite an extraordinary
number to be off by also the Dow above
26,000 points you mentioned the Nasdaq
setting the record seven million jobs
9,000 opportunity zones
here the jobs president you did this
once you brought 7 million jobs and
quite clearly what the markets are
saying is they remember that coronavirus
job creation numbers were lower than
during the end of Barack Obama's
presidency they slowed down don't let
them trick you about that sometimes
gonna be better than the first I think
Steve we have a shot at it right ok
please
yes I'm Anthony going send I'm honored
to be here mr. president
representing the state of Nebraska we
were really focused on three things in
terms of making sure that our economy
stayed on track and first it was
stabilization so the PPP the ID alone
gave us the liquidity injection that we
needed to help us out debt servicing our
community banks work very closely with
the small businesses to defer payments
and then we move into recovery and when
we talk about recovery the 1.08 billion
dollars that we've received from
Treasury has been a huge help we've
broken it down into four programs small
business stabilization rural broadband
we're given a million dollars for Gallup
and then we're also looking at taking
workers that are in industries that are
shrinking and retraining them in
high-demand industries so we can put
Nebraskans back to work in the
restaurant not listening yeah rural
broadband and we're doing that very big
for the Middle West and for our farmers
and that's a very big factor and as you
know we've started the process already
right yes and I think you're gonna be
very happy with it absolutely thank you
so much appreciate it
good afternoon mr. president
so it's not Ivanka governor's
secretaries directors and honored guests
my name is Melissa Haggerty and I'm
proud and honored to be the invited
guests of governor Ricketts from the
great state of Nebraska oh my god I am a
wife and mother to two young daughters
ages 9 and 11 as well as the co-owner of
four bakeries in Nebraska and Iowa we've
been in business for 10 years and of
approximately 92 employees early on in
Koga 19 we decided not to layoff any
employees rather ask the ones that live
at home with their parents to scale back
on some of their hours if they can by
doing that it would give the other
employees that needed their shifts to be
able to cover their rent and other
expenses an opportunity to keep their
hours most of our employees are in their
early 20s
with no families to fall back on so it
was critical for us to take care of them
any way we could it was an important
decision for the federal government to
allow each state's governor to decide
how to formulate their own plan of how
to close and in turn reopen their states
fortunately my business is in both
Nebraska and Iowa were able to continue
to serve our guests inside the bakery
while practicing social distancing
sanitizing between guests all while
everyone wears a mask
we have several terrible weeks of sales
leading into Easter it was easily the
scariest time of my life as a business
owner not knowing what would happen next
we did apply for and receive paycheck
protection program funds through a small
locally owned bank who we've had a
strong relationship with since we
started back in 2010 this Trump program
has been helpful for us to continue to
meet our fiduciary obligations in terms
of promises to our staff as well as
paying our monthly bills as the you know
it's funny more people are watching my
stream than the actual official White
House stream of this like in other words
we've generated more interest in this
than the White House YouTube channel has
generated for their own event isn't that
weird our bottom line additional
employees have been added to answer the
phones and runners are needed to take
orders out to the guests waiting in
their car by mid-may sales tribology no
no the best Mother's Day ever seeing
double-digit growth over last year's
weekly sales so my Nebraska bakeries
have now entered phase 3 seems to be
tweeting at governor Ricketts directed
health measures we anticipate our guests
desire to celebrate all of the life's
events they missed over the past three
months new babies
birthdays anniversaries retirements
with our ultimate hope that it will
transfer into a much busier summer than
we normally would have I want to thank
you for inviting me to be a part of this
important discussion thank you very much
great job thank you very much please the
hell is this microphone Thank You mr.
president I am honored to be here
representing small independent
restaurant industry and the great state
of Oklahoma
thank you for inviting me I am a small
independent restaurant editor I own and
operate Stella modern Italian cuisine in
Oklahoma City my restaurant celebrated
10 years in business in April prior to
covet 19 I employed 30 people in the
restaurant when restaurants were closed
for inside dining I was furlough some
very dedicated and loyal employees for
the first time ever since I did receive
the PPP financial assistance I was able
to offer all of our staff their jobs
back and all but three returned I want
to thank you and governor stit for
working so hard for our economy and
helping us reopen in a responsible and
systematic way our industry worked very
closely with Governor stit and the
Health Department of Oklahoma on
guidelines to reopen with a phased
approach it has been good to get back to
work and to be able to serve our guests
and it religiously adopted in Oklahoma
we are using data-driven points to
ensure we are reopening our restaurants
and economy in a safe in an efficient
manner oh my god our number one goal has
been to keep our Trump is tweeting
during the event as well as our
employees we know there is work to be
done to create a sense of confidence in
our diners as well as our only buzz and
help people feel good about dining out
again we are diligently following
guidelines on using PPP for I'm sorry
PPE for our employees doubling our
sanitation practice and encouraging our
customers to follow the suggested
guidelines for social distancing
restaurants have always had outstanding
protocol in place for safely preparing
food and serving our customers in a safe
manner as you're aware the registry has
suffered greatly during this
unpresentable has been ever whelming
we're working so hard for our economy
like this this lady can't even read the
thing Trump's tweeting while she speaks
anyway so it doesn't matter I mean this
is this is a joke economy at large get
back to work there is more that needs to
be done and we appreciate the
opportunity we have to work closely with
you your administration and our
congressional leaders for next steps to
get our economy and our industry back to
work and fully open oh my president trap
america's restaurant industry is
grateful for your leadership in guiding
us through this pandemic thank you again
for inviting me to meet with you and
thank you for governor still for your
leadership governor's tip that always
sound like hearings back to work and get
deductions back for your restaurant
industry and you can look at that man
right over there he'll be carrying the
message but we're looking for the
deductions for entertainment restaurants
I'm sick of winning you'll get it right
back bigger than before okay working
very hard on that please Thank You mr.
president honored to represent the
lodging industry before America's first
hotel your president grateful to
governor's Ted for his leadership and
for the invitation to join today my name
is Pete Patel first generation American
my family and I immigrated to the United
States in 1979 in search of the American
dream
now Trump's right we found that American
dream in Tulsa Oklahoma
small hotel your small business and
hotel years our company owns and
operates 12 hotels in eastern Oklahoma
the current crisis lodging was the first
to suffer because of shelter in place
and we will be the last to recover it
may take up to two years before kovat
our industry had record occupancies
profitability and new development hotels
thanks to the exceptional strong economy
under your leadership mr. president
because of kovat occupancy dropped at 20
percent nationally revenues fell by 50%
and 70% of all hotel employees were
either laid off are furloughed for the
first time in my career we were forced
to lay off employees and that was the
most gut-wrenching experience that we've
had the protection program was a
lifeline to our industry to help
America's small businesses and our
employees the best thing for our
business is that our economy also
embarrassing us grateful to Oklahoma
governor for his systematic data-driven
approach to leading our state back to
opening currently our occupancies have
picked up a bit but we still have a long
ways to go as an industry as well as our
market the hospitality industry as a
whole
translated our reopening here my hotels
in a safe and healthy manner the
industry has implemented what's called
safe stay standards
sanitization PPE use social distancing
things like limiting buffets and using
grab-and-go
prepackaged items swimming pools and
gyms are limited with appointments for
use guests and employees are only safe
as as how we make the properties and we
have done the hotel industry has done a
great job in adapting ways to make sure
all our boys as guests are safe mr.
president I would like to mention a
couple of
we need more states to reopen consumers
to feel safe to travel industry will
need additional resources to help pay
our bills increase cap on the idle
program would be very helpful to us and
we need pressure relief from our local
banks who may be stressed in these times
coming up that have hospitality loans we
will need help from the federal reserve
and FDIC on those two companies this
guy's asking Trump for help to lose mr.
president talking to somebody else
america's hotel yours are grateful for
your leadership appreciate we appreciate
and you know what it's like to own and
operate hotels we are looking forward to
working with you towards a swift and
strong recovery thank you I'm impressed
by your 20% number that was your low
point you're better than any hotel
company that I've seen we had Hilton
then there were a 1% right and we had we
had all of the big ones and they were
from one to four or five percent so if
you're at 20 percent congratulations
that's pretty good that was the average
mr. president there was a few of them
that weren't that you know Thank You mr.
president thank you as your domestic
policy chief what an honor it is to have
all of these small business owners here
at the White House I'm reminded that
just yesterday mr. president we had
veterans in the day before we were doing
policing reform in the Rose Garden the
day before that we were talking about
seniors and taking care of our elderly
and fraud everything you do every day
every minute is how to do the most for
all Americans and the small business
this is the backbone of our country I'm
from a town of 1,200 people Glen Rose
Texas an hour south of Dallas raised by
a single mom who had a flower shop on
the Main Street of Glen Rose small
business truly is the American dream and
it's very very best and the work that
secretary minuchin that administrator
Carranza are doing for this country is
extraordinary but it's executing your
vision and so bringing today these small
business owners to the White House
talking about how we're going to not
just get this country back where we were
just a couple months ago before the
indemic from china hit but to even
greater heights than ever before it's
just an honor to be here and i want to
welcome and thank everyone for coming to
the White House and thank you mr.
president for your leadership thank you
very much okay thank you all very much
thank you thank you very much
oh he's not taking questions oh he's not
gonna take questions he's getting
crushed by the Supreme oh my god they
just wrapped he didn't take any
questions after all of that BS
unbelievable unbelievable and here's
Trump tweeting let's see if he ended up
tweeting multiple times no just the one
time during the during of the thing
unbelievable what an incredible
incredible propaganda event all right my
friends I've got to go out and plant
some grass seed in my garden I
appreciate everybody who joined me we
did not get the questions answered that
we were hoping for but thank you so much
twitch it's just going so well YouTube
is going so well make sure to subscribe
if you're on YouTube follow if you're on
twitch this stuff is free and I'll see
you on the next one which will be it'll
be sooner than you think let me put it
that way
you